hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to yandere simulator in
this episode we're gonna try to get our
rival boobs McKenzie expelled from
school and they should be arriving soon
hello my fellow claw
alright the Frick are you okay so
there's numerous things that you can do
to get your rival expelled from school
the number one thing you can do is rely
on info Chan who if you didn't know is a
bit of a creepy group or obvious okay
there we go
friggin lewd don't mind me hey yeah you
go in there fellow students
I'm just creeping out sorry pardon me
are never gonna ignore what I'm doing
right now because it's really really
like really creepy my wife is that is
that wait wait whoa hang on whoa hang on
a second hang on wait a minute what hi
what the [ __ ]
don't don't do that stop being shy don't
stop it stop being shy
what got you huh huh okay my waifu
described as kawaii moe
and dare dare by her admirers has sworn
her heart to an independent game
developer living overseas prefers to
spend time alone fantasizing about her
loved one Wow looks like the developer
has a crush good things not boobs
McKenzie good thing it's not sand right
that that that I need to get this ah
Wow somebody's gonna look at me loves or
ease up I'm so weird
oh ha here we go schemes so you go to
info Chan and then you have schemes that
you can do expose dirty thief or it a
thin frame for theft smoking panty shots
and cheating so the easiest one to do is
smoking I believe
pick cigarettes I could have done that I
already knew that gave me some cigs
pleasure pleasure pleasure doing
business with you
Wow so she drops them from the upper
storey window up there actually let me
show you that just so you guys don't
think that I'm ready [ __ ] around pack
of cigarettes drop it Oh apparently she
never mind she's not gonna do that huh
10 class oh that was supposed to be the
coup de grâce oh I'm supposed to do
these one every day
oh wow I [ __ ] everything up [ __ ] okay
so we're starting back again and this
time I think I actually do have pictures
of everybody which is really creepy and
disturbing yeah why
needed to be done question mark ravages
verbal actions in order to do so I have
I need schemes I'm gonna expose a dirty
secret think so in the services menu I
need to purchase a dirty secret and then
report it to the counselor provide dark
secret nice you're gonna love this I've
got video footage of Kaukauna selling
used panties to a boy from a new danger
danger it's horrible you with this is
thank you for bringing this to my
attention I know kind of conduct will
definitely harm the school's reputation
exactly to have a word with her later
today
you should have several words this is
bad okay anyway next game we need to
frame for theft I got it for lunch and
then later for smoking
I might as well get all these now I
guess cuz I can buy [ __ ] I need one more
picture I'm gonna get those cigarettes
but this time oh I can show you oh I can
show you won't that be fun alright so
the drop happens right by here so if I
look here and you go in here and you get
a favor and you not that you get a drop
and a pack of cigarettes and then you
get out of here oink and / Boop
okay and there you go you got this you
take this upstairs to her bag and then
put it into her bag and then report her
- I should probably put this as my
current scheme by the way yeah they're
real all right place cigarettes in your
rivals bag which is exactly what I
intend to do mine the third floor then
you put this inner bag and then you can
go right back down to the counselor and
tell her about the horrible thing that
you just did but don't say it was you
say was boobs McKenzie she'll believe
that teacher-teacher is horrible
kids are smugger okay sir yes I can only
do this one today okay Emery don't this
is easy teach first I'm gonna steal me a
ring cuz that's what I like to do so
right here if we just accelerate time a
bit
there we go she put the ring down and
then I take it to ring okay so I'm only
gonna frame her for so many things at
once but it seems like today things are
generally done so we're gonna go to
class we're gonna do the psychology
because I don't feel like doing anything
else and we're going to do the thing
with the thing okay goodbye everybody
goodbye goodbye
[ __ ] okay there we go the guidance
counselor asked ACOTA
or boobs and Kizzy uh-huh your
after-school activities are completely
unacceptable
you should not be conducting yourself in
such a manner this kind of behavior
could cause a scandal you can run the
school's reputation into the ground
Oh No
boobs McKenzie what happened to you I
tend to get a bit of sleep yeah here we
got tomorrow to deal with and then
another thing to frame her for tomorrow
okay I know that noise huh where am I
going oh god I don't even know counselor
where's the counselor over here okay
danger teacher wait was this the right
scheme what do you mean theft yeah
theft okay so I should do that first
now do the smoking first can I help you
that's a clear violation rules I know I
just she's horrible someone saw her
someone stop me
oh I need to take a look in your bag Oh
cigarette oh you have absolutely no
excuse to be carrying something like
this around oh I don't smoke I don't
know why something like this was in my
bow okay anyway next go to sleep with
sweet dreams of senpai failing my head
and
whoopty well no did your teacher again
I'm such a tattletale
I'd hate to think we have a thief here
at school no we do I'll get to the
bottom of and the murderer but that's a
whole nother story don't worry about
that one I'm just just focus on the now
of the things because that's all we can
do as humans Oh may I take a look inside
your oh this doesn't belong to you does
it
hey what are you doing with someone
else's property oh okay anyway another
successful day time to drip of sweets
and bye he's for me engine engine okay
target acquired
bibbidi-bobbidi bibbidi-bobbidi-boo inc
okay got that steel phone goodbye take a
panty shot whatever I did it of myself
Ziya and I are probably a time to be
super stealthy about it
no one was Invicta thing which is Swift
dairy oh yeah
boink there we go save that I'm down
here ice and bye hi I love you I love
you Oh guys it's up with oh nothing I
just declared my love among the rose
petals it was going to be beautiful I'm
sorry okay so I think I can go to class
and I think I can go to class again if I
write and so this will be before okay so
I need to go to the cooking club right
away
in the cooking club I believe is on the
first floor right by the faculty room
cooking club here we go so I need to put
this right yeah there we go
now I need to wait for her to find it
which means that I just need to be right
here she's gonna find her phone and then
I go right to the cab learn haha okay so
got that and then counselors office
teacher teacher teacher what can I help
you with Wow serious accusation Wow
you're not lying to me why would I it's
just a misunderstanding
Wow that's to get the matter oh don't
mind me screaming right in your face
okay you gonna I guess I'm done alright
goodbye then goodbye everybody have a
lovely time may I see your phone for a
moment what is this I don't care to
explain why something like this is on
your phone Oh what I've never taken any
pictures like that Oh
only one more step left
do you expel my rival my rifle will be
destroyed hahahaha the last scheme is
for cheating yes you're doing business
with you pleasure doing business with
you alright
okay faculty room take this take this we
go upstairs into info Chan's domain and
then she will help us here we go and
Rosanna this one's free don't get used
to it okay why would you I'm only a
murdering psychopath why wouldn't you
juniors trust me okay so now we should
be able to put this duplicated desk
check first step duplicate fog we should
be able to put this duplicated
thingamabob er
onto her desk right about now funk soul
brother
and then reporter oh my god sent by
you're about to love me there no Angelo
who would you love but
okay teacher teacher teacher oh no you
will I'll investigate the matter if she
is cheating I'll catch her in the act
good okay so that means that as I go to
class we're gonna see something happen
is cuz I learned so much about
psychology you don't use this inside of
your desk
oh and answer sheet ed you're cheating
unacceptable come with me obviously we
need to have a long talk about the kind
of behavior that will not be tolerated
at this school yes oh no someone's
getting it enough second chances you
have repeatedly broken school rules and
ignored every warning that I have given
you you have left me with no choice but
to permanently expel you oh so now I
wonder if I go home after this if I go
home
is it gonna show the normal game over
where bad things happen or is it gonna
be some sort of pleasant resolution whoo
go [ __ ] with that dark looking fella
okay so maybe maybe maybe maybe
ah come on but [ __ ] what's a rival
oh okay that's just cuz no victory is
implemented yet into the game so that
just means that it just hasn't been
built in yet but it's getting there so
that is how you expel your rival so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you want to see in the
next episode of yandere simulator and
I'll get to it in a short while thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
Oh where's chica chica
but I don't know would I know I need to
fill my head with love by kissing minima
and back of it the nape of his neck
everybody stop looking at me like that